what's your name  sorry  we need to talk to you about the four  dead girls you ever seen these girls  before my suspect that's yours right the  lighter it was found at the crime scene  we got motive we got access  cops wanted to confirm you're on your  way to see me last night  the bald one he thought i'd be all bent  about you flirting with those poor girls  why don't you tell me who you think's  involved i have nothing to do with it i  got someone trying to pin a bunch of  murders on me in broad daylight i'm not  going back inside especially not for  something i didn't do  what am i into  show business son  i don't think you're involved in this  any more than somebody wants you to be  okay sauce i told you about when she was  abducted  i told you to be ready  you